what is taking place in ukraine
now is horrific it's it's painful
and we see human suffering we see
destruction at the scale we haven't seen
in europe since the second world war and
i would like to commend the courage of
the ukrainian people standing up against
the
russian invasion standing up against
putin's forces
and that was the reason why
we are stepping up our support
and also why nato allies have
implemented
the most severe sanctions ever
and also why we are mobilizing support
from the whole world in condemning and
calling on russia
and president putin to end this war
at the same time we have a
responsibility as nato allies
to prevent this war from
escalating beyond ukraine
because that will be even more dangerous
more devastating
and uh will cause even more human
suffering
so
we are made to clear that we are not
going to move into ukraine
neither on the ground or in the
ukrainian airspace
and of course the only way to
implement an old fly zone is to send
nato planes fighter planes into
ukrainian airspace
and then impose that no fly zone by
shooting down russian planes
and our assessment is that we understand
the desperation
but we also
believe that if we did that
we'll end up with something that could
end in a full-fledged war in europe
involving many more countries
and
causing much more human suffering
so that's the reason why we
make this painful decision
to impose heavy sanctions
provide significant support stepping up
support for the same time time not
involving nato and nato forces directly
in the conflict uh in ukraine neither on
ground or in airspace i strongly believe
that if nato become directly involved in
the conflict
we will see more human suffering more
civilian killed civilians killed and
that's the reason why we need to
to
step up support
impose heavy sanctions
call for russia to engage in a political
solution
but not involve nato our main
responsibility our core task is to
protect and defend one billion people
living in 30 allied countries we are
doing that by increasing the presence
of nato forces
in the eastern part alliance deploying
for the first time the nato response
force but you are not going to be part
of their conflict with russia in ukraine